here's a rundown of what happened in the
European Parliament in Strasbourg this
week Emmie peas themselves were Charlie
on Monday freedom of expression and
tolerance they said our two
non-negotiable European values they held
a minute's silence to pay tribute to the
victims of terrorism of last week's
attacks in Paris and of the atrocities
committed by Boko Haram in Nigeria the
rotating presidency of the EU taking
over from Italy Latvia for the first
time took charge its target is a
competitive digital Europe with a strong
international presence Latvians also say
there is some cause for hope on Ukraine
with potential resolution to the
conflict within six months GMOs everyone
can do as they please in other words the
cultivation of GMOs is authorized across
Europe but countries can impose a ban on
their territory if the argument against
is sufficiently strong the European
Union on the international stage
federica mogherini I representative of
the union for foreign affairs and
security policy wants there to be more
coordination in the fight against
terrorism needless to say there were
discussions in Parliament surrounding
the attacks in Paris but also Libya and
Egypt closer to home ms mogherini wants
to renew dialogue with Russia to resolve
the conflict in Ukraine while keeping
sanctions in place press freedom is
under the spotlight but this time in
Turkey m ep's condemned recent police
raids there and the detention of several
journalists and media representatives
they're asking the Turkish judicial
authorities to review the cases as soon
as possible
you